lines are closed this is cool  that was Kaley Cuoco failing a hard  calling into the bachelors live after  show last week I called in to ask my  questions that the fans supposedly get  to call in and ask I was not allowed to  I'm just putting it out there so Ben  Higgins I have questions for you and I  will save my questions until I get  through and I will be on my phone when I  get in my car to try and get through  tonight  okay Kaley we've got some good news for  you Meucci gave Bachelor Ben the chance  to right that wrong one we caught up  with him over the weekend when it's  faintly gonna be on The Bachelor Live  you guys got to offer her that week  probably make that happen we should  really work on that you should look into  our camera and say Kaley we're gonna  take care of you that would make her day  Kaley we're gonna take care of you and  get you on Bachelor live if you'll  accept I love that